in jurassic world dominion
the park is gone
and dinosaurs are everywhere
owen claire and maisie are living off
the grid
had a baby that's impossible
girl
you look just like your mother
[Music]
i promise i am gonna get her back
jurassic world dominion gave us the
opportunity to take the franchise to new
and different places
i have to fix a terrible mistake that
i've made
you coming or what
i have to warn you everyone's so excited
to have you you guys are absolute
legends around here our storylines
intersect we get to reacquaint with all
friends and get to know new friends
it feels like this is the closing of a
chapter
willing risk your life for people you
never met
you want to ask questions or you want to
ride
i thought it was a fantastic idea to
bring these two worlds together
i made a promise we would bring her home
you made a promise
to a dinosaur yeah
why
jurassic world dominion is the
culmination of the franchise
we give you something that you want but
do not expect
[Applause]
that can't be right i've never seen
action like this ever
the most scary and awesome dinosaurs
you've ever seen
what is that
[Music]
[Music]
you